hello and welcome you're watching the
daily climate show coming up
the uk's emissions targets net zero by
2050 won't be reached with current
policies according to a new report
the eu agrees new cars must be emissions
free after 2035
and nato announces its first ever
climate targets aiming for a 45
emissions reduction across the alliance
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show where we track the changes
happening to our planet hear from those
hit hardest by those changes and reports
on the race for solutions now the uk is
not delivering on its climate goals
that's the conclusion drawn from a new
report released today by the climate
change committee the government's
independent advisors they found major
failures in the delivery of programmes
working to achieve the uk's goal of
becoming net zero by 2050. now last year
the uk's greenhouse gas emissions were
47 below what they were in 1990 that is
one of the fastest declines among
industrialized nations
but plans for cutting emissions will
need to be strengthened for the uk's
climate targets to be met according to
the committee now this is the
government's current pathway for
reducing emissions up to the year 2037.
credible plans exist for 39 of the
emission cuts needed to get there but
there are risks attached to plans for
nearly 60
of the required reductions either
because they're still under development
or because they have no clear timeline
and for five percent of the required
emission reductions plans are either
inadequate or missing altogether now one
of the greatest policy failures the
report found was on installation with
rates of improvement in energy
efficiency continuing to be well below
the necessary level our climate change
in energy correspondent hannah thomas
peter has this report
lord deben is the chairman of the
climate change committee and he's
delivering a grim report on government
plans to get to net zero carbon
emissions by 2050.
his verdict lots of grand promises but
nowhere near enough detail
as things stand with the current program
that the government has
net zero will not happen that is true
quite a number of departments have not
yet got into their stride and what we're
saying is we haven't got any time to
wait you know this is very serious it's
no longer possible to ignore the fact
that we will make this planet
uninhabitable if we don't act now among
the major failures identified the
committee describes a shocking gap in
policy for better insulated homes
richard shears already knows this all
too well he made his house more energy
efficient without any government
guidance and now helps others to do the
same
it can be confusing for people starting
on the retrofit journey because there
are so many different points of contact
and there's so many different messages
out there that
knowing where to start can be can be a
real headache
agriculture and land use are also
singled out for what's described as
glacial progress we really do want to
see that incentivization we want to see
that policy uh really help farmers
formulate a plan but i think we do need
government to take it seriously but it's
not all bad news
the report says that great progress has
been made on electric vehicles and on
renewable energy but it will make for
very uncomfortable reading for the
government
and for boris johnson who as prime
minister has consistently said that
action on climate change is a top
priority
his critics though have never been
convinced
we have a prime minister who essentially
is a climate cheat he's using all the
language to suggest that he's taking
action on climate change but as this
damning report makes so clear he
literally is not doing that there is
this big gulf between his words and his
action
in a statement a government spokesperson
said over the past three decades the uk
has driven down emissions faster than
any other g7 country and we have clear
plans to go further
we are leading the world on climate
change helping over 90 percent of
countries set net zero targets during
our cop 26 presidency up from 30 percent
two years ago
but grabbing the headlines and
delivering on the detail at home are two
very different things and the chasm
between the two must be closed if the
government is to keep its promises on
tackling climate change
hannah thomas peters sky news in
westminster
well joining us now is chaitanya kumar
head of environment and green transition
at the new economics foundation mr kumar
thank you very much for being with us
here on the climate show now it's not a
good look for the government this uh how
can they be made to adopt the
recommendations
i think the the committee's role is to
basically give
a rigorous dispassionate analysis of
where we are and where we are isn't a
good place we obviously made some good
progress in the power sector primarily
but the the thing is a lot of the
changes we've seen in the past sector
are out of sight and therefore quite out
of mind for a lot of people and the
biggest challenge which they've
identified now of course is the heating
and building sector our homes are some
of the leakiest coldest homes in europe
you know and insulating them and
ensuring heat uh that the heat that we
use to warm our homes actually comes
from cleaner sources sort of natural gas
is a big priority so they have got a
very clear set of recommendations in
fact they've got 100 pages of
recommendations in what is one of the
largest longest reports they've produced
and i think the government knows uh at
least in this area that they've got a
lot of work to do and
we just need to see a lot more policy
action in this place
you mentioned that idea of insulation
the government recently said that they
would give up one billion pounds towards
insulating people who um were in
low-income communities for their homes i
mean how far do you think that could go
towards helping
i think it is playing a very important
role so i think i think i'll give the
government credit there but it is a very
small piece of the puzzle uh the
government so the climate change
committee's report basically identifies
that we need about 350 billion pounds of
investment not all public to be clear
it's public money and private capital
that needs to go in but about 350
billion pounds if we need to insulate
and reduce carbon emissions completely
from our housing sector and we're
nowhere near that i think the biggest
gap is the report identifies is what is
called the owner occupied sector that is
homes where
homes that are occupied by the owners
cells that's a big sector more than half
of the country's homes have owners
occupying them and there's absolutely no
policy to actually help incentivize them
to undertake the measures be it
insulating their cavities insulating
their lofts ensuring that they have low
carbon heat in the form of heat pumps
for example there's absolutely zero
policy to actually help them now quasi
quartering the business and energy
minister at a select committee hearing
this morning in fact said that we can
expect some new policy but until the
details are clear
we can safely say and as the company
that we are nowhere close to reaching at
zero in the building sector
and shaytania quickly if you can i
wonder how would the uk be able to
balance you know um reducing fossil fuel
extraction with energy security right
now because it's very important of
course that we have access to our own
energy supplies in light of what's
happening in ukraine
yeah i think i think the greatest
resource we've got is wind
with the blast with abundant sources of
wind energy it's got a bit of solar
we've got geothermal energy and marine
energy there's lots of renewable energy
sources that you can really tap i think
the era of fossil fuels is well behind
us it'll be foolish for any policymaker
any minister to basically come out now
and say
when gas prices are so high that to get
us out of this crisis is to actually
invest more in gas that is absolutely
foolish and we shouldn't be investing
more of our scarce resource
into fossil fuels when we've got cleaner
cheaper and and more renewable sources
that we can export okay che chanyakuma i
appreciate your time today so thank you
so much for being with us
now in other news today in both the
european union and nato have made
significant pledges towards tackling
climate change eu countries reached a
deal backing stricter rules on car
emissions it came after marathon talks
which concluded early this morning the
agreement looks to eliminate carbon
emissions from new cars by 2035. now the
deal was agreed after italy withdrew an
attempt for a five-year delay to the
plans
and nato announced targets to reduce its
emissions of first for the military
alliance the organization described the
climate crisis as the overarching
challenge of our time speaking at the
summit in madrid nato chief yen
stoltenberg said the 30-member alliance
would reduce emissions by at least 45
percent by 2030 and reach net zero
emissions by 2050.
let's get some more of the day's climate
news now first to austria
well this was the scene at last night as
heavy rain and floods hit villages in
the southern state of corinthia one
person is known to have died and one
person is missing authorities have
declared a civil emergency after some
villages in the area were cut off by
mudslides there are warnings that more
rain could be coming
a cocktail of more than 150 pesticides
is harming wildlife in the uk's
countryside a charity has warned the
royal society for the protection of
birds said the combined quantity of
chemicals being used could cover the uk
and its farmland 10 times every year the
rspb warned regulation for pesticides
does not properly assess the real world
impacts of the chemicals being used
and just before we leave we want to know
your climate questions anything that's
ever mystified you or whatever you want
to get to the bottom of if you scan the
qr code on your screen right now you can
send us your questions which will be
answered on our brand new climate show
this weekend hosted by the environmental
broadcaster and author tom heap now it
starts this saturday the 2nd of july at
3 30 pm here on sky news